je ne sais pas s'il y a encore
trop de chiens ou s'il y a des chiens tués
intentionnellement, nous ne savons pas vraiment
ce qui se passe dans ces refuges pour animaux,
nous avons encore un long chemin à parcourir
pour rendre le monde meilleur pour
eux
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
étranger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme d'habitude nous
avons fait beaucoup de castration pour les chiens des rues
vous voyez comme vous pouvez le voir au début
c'était peut-être
le sixième chien quatrième jour nous voulons juste
arrêter
d'avoir  chiots dans la rue et je
suppose que c'est notre
façon
d'arrêter ce problème
non, ils
disent qu'ils disent qu'ils le gardent toujours
très vrai, je veux dire qu'ils
connaissent les problèmes qu'ils ont, ils
savent qu'ils n'ont pas assez de
nourriture pour subvenir aux besoins de tout le monde
et
bien sûr, ils vous le feront savoir comme
hé si ça marche ça marche si  c'est pas
ouais on va les euthanasier d'accord
ouais c'est comme la dure réalité
ils te font savoir ça surtout ouais
mais pas à chaque fois que ça arrive tu
sais pas à chaque fois
[Musique] [
Musique]
euh
[Musique]
important dans notre pays  les gens
ne sont pas si ouverts à adopter des chiens donc nous n'avons
que trois ou quatre adoptions par an
[Musique]
est
condition
[Musique]
oh